Gershund therapy recommends a no salt diet.
Is this how we should be eating?
I don't think so.
So remember, and I write about this in my book as well.
Some of the things that are in the Gershund therapy
that are go way back from in the 1930s and 40s,
when Max Gershund wrote his book.
So if you read Max Gershund's book,
you'll read things about absolutely nobody should be taking salt.
Everybody should be on the task.
Things like that that were part of his original program.
Well, Charlotte Gershund has not changed anything
from Max Gershund's original program.
Some doctors that worked with her for a number of years,
I know a German doctor that worked with her for a number of years
and just trying to get her to go.
Let's come in to the 21st century here.
There's more data.
There's more research.
She just absolutely refused.
She stays true to his program.
And there's good things and bad things about them.
But I do think there's benefit to looking at new research and new data.
They can both prove that the efficacy of some of the things that you've done.
But it could also discrew some of the things that you've done.
And we as practitioners need to stay humble in that new data comes out.
And we've got to go, wow, this is really interesting.
I need to start testing for this or start applying this.
Or boy, what I was doing now, I don't think was really correct.
And we need to be humble enough to change that.
That goes for all of us.
So as far as I know, so diet, I don't think so.
Oh, I will say with salt.
There are some people.
There's a percentage of the population that is so sensitive.
That has been proven with with with with research around autoimmune disease and research around blood pressure and quarter heart disease.
Some people that are sodium sensitive.
Well, sodium chloride will attach to receptors in the smooth muscle underneath the epithelial and cause contraction and increased blood pressure.
But the studies that I saw about over two thirds of the people are not sodium sensitive that it causes.
And the engagement with that receptor in it and sodium doesn't increase blood pressure.
Well, when that with some of that initial research came out, that's when, you know, they started saying back in the 70s and 80s and all high blood pressure people should limit their sodium.
That's only true in a percentage of population of coronary patients that are sodium sensitive.
There's also a sodium sensitivity.
It can bind to receptors on immune cells and cause immune people with autoimmune disease to worsen, especially with Hashimoto's.
I write about that information.
I think I've actually created video on it by the clinic disease and all of you in course in the last module.
More specifically on caution, photos in autoimmune thyroid.
That is relatively new information.
And people with Hashimoto's many of them that have that sodium sensitivity for their thyroid gland do much better at taking.
And for many people, it's just called down the triggers immensely.
More information on the module six, I think it is on the autoimmune course.
But, but I don't, I don't think, I see it, I don't think for most people with cancer that they have to be on a no salt diet.